you recommend your patients or anyone in general
taking melatonin in larger doses,
either by therapeutic purposes such as cancer,
heart or brain related or other conditions
or for prevention, thank you.
So, the answer is yes,
but we typically only do that,
I recommend that for cancer.
So melatonin in larger doses
is really an oxidative agent.
So it's important to understand
things that you would do for cancer
can be very different than things
that you would do for other health conditions.
You would normally, if you did not have a diagnosis of cancer,
you would want to reduce oxidative stress
because oxidative stress can be a cause of cancer.
So your body has a way to limit and reduce oxidative stress.
So what is oxidative stress?
Oxidative stress is classified as
what are called reactive oxygen species,
reactive nitrogen species.
That bond to your cell membranes,
that bond to your mitochondrial membranes,
your other organelles,
can damage organelles, can damage the nucleus of the cell
and can be a cause of cancer.
So those are oxidative agents.
So typically most poisons and pesticides
and toxins and heavy metals
and even endotoxins that your body produces
can produce oxidative stress.
Your body produces oxidative stress
through its metabolic processes normally.
And oxidative stress has benefits.
So when your body produces reactive oxygen species,
it's typically for the purpose of killing pathogens
or it's a byproduct of metabolism.
So it can be just a byproduct of metabolic pathways
and then it's reduced.
So those oxidative oxygen species are reduced
through antioxidant agents that your body produces.
So your body produces the main antioxidant agent
that your body produces is glutathione.
That is your number one intracellular antioxidant.
It reduces those reactive oxygen and nitrogen species
to inner substances and gets rid of them.
It helps your body get rid of those.
We also produce glutathione in the liver,
helps with phase one, phase two, pathways in the liver.
So normally you have this tug of war
between oxidative stress and reducing oxidative stress.
It's tug of war between antioxidants and antioxidants.
Remember, nothing in your body, let's say, is all bad, okay?
So it has a purpose.
So the purpose of heavy reactive oxygen species
in your body is that you will help kill pathogens.
So let's say if I have a bacterial infection,
my body will actually make more reactive oxidative species
to help the immune system kill pathogens.
And so it has a benefit.
However, there's a danger it just being out of balance.
So whatever, it's just all about balance.
So you have this balance of oxidative agents
and a balance of antioxidants that your body makes.
Now, we are told if you look at different nutritional circles,
you're told that you should be eating tons of antioxidants
because you're exposed to somebody reactive oxygen species.
And I would agree with that.
So normally, you are exposed, okay, let's say,
let's say 200 years ago, well, it's not even true then
because people were to colonize it, you know,
produce reactive oxygen species and stuff too.
But in today's society, we are exposed to a lot of chemicals
that our ancestors were never exposed to.
Those are oxidizing agents
and those can be cancer causers.
So our cancer causers, because they damage cell membranes,
they damage mitochondrial membranes,
they damage the nucleus of the cell
and they can cause the cell nucleus
be damaged to go into rapid replication
so it can be actually a cause of cancer
because of a lot of ill health.
So taking a lot of antioxidants can be good advice
for someone to prevent cancer.
So why am I saying this?
We're talking about melatonin because melatonin
at a normal dosage, which would be like three milligrams per day
to help you fall asleep, taking that half hour to an hour
before bedtime that will help you go to sleep.
And at three to six milligrams a day, 10 milligrams a day,
it's considered, it has an antioxidant properties as well.
So it functions as an antioxidant as well.
But in a higher dosage, we're talking 40, 60, 80,
120, 100, 200 milligrams doses,
then it functions as an oxidized agent.
So there are certain nutrients that at higher doses
actually function as an oxidized agent, not an antioxidant.
That is important to know that because, you know,
too much of a good thing can be a bad thing.
So something in a different dose
could actually have a completely different function
of your body.
It's also important to know that because if you are,
if you are, do we the, do we the, an oxidative therapy
for cancer.
So understand, if you're trying to treat cancer,
cancer cells by the, by the very act of bead
in rapid replication are producing relatively unhealthy cells.
Let's say not as healthy as normal cells.
And because of that, they're already producing
a lot of oxidative stress.
So they're already near that lethal dose
of oxidative stress, which would kill, which could kill them.
So we can actually harness that knowledge
and add oxidizing agents to that person, not antioxidant.
So first of all, cancer is trying to take antioxidant
so they don't get cancer.
But once you have a diagnosis of cancer,
you don't necessarily want to be taking antioxidant.
You want to be taking oxidizing agents.
So many alternative therapies are oxidizing,
terrified therapies.
Leotrial B17, that's an oxidizing therapy.
Protocel is an oxidizing therapy.
Hydose vitamin C is an oxidizing therapy.
Hydose melatonin is an oxidizing therapy.
Hydose vitamin E, especially delta,
total treat all, is an oxidizing therapy.
So it's understand that's a natural approach.
Actually, chemo therapy is an oxidizing agent.
That's how chemo therapy works.
It increases oxidative stress.
And it will help tip over cancer cells
because they're already near that lethal dose
where healthy cells have that balance
and their mitochondria is functioning well
and they're producing a lot of glutathiles
so they're getting rid of oxidative stress.
Cancer cells have less than healthy mitochondria.
They're not producing enough glutathione
to get rid of oxidative stress.
So they're already producing a lot of wrapped oxygen species
and they're near that lethal dose of self-death of lysis.
Because of my oxidative stress
and if you could give them more oxidative stress
gives chemo therapy, you will kill cancer cells
prior to killing healthy cells.
Now, the good thing about an alternative oxidative therapy
for cancer is that it spares the healthy cells.
So it doesn't damage healthy cells
where chemo therapy can kill healthy cells as well.
So, long answer to the question,
do I recommend high dose melatonin
for cancer, heart or brain related issues?
It's only appartial, yes.
I only recommend it for cancer.
High dose melatonin for heart or brain related issues.
I wouldn't use it for that
because you're increasing oxidative stress.
There's no reason why you'd wanna increase oxidative stress
to cardiac tissue.
I'd have to see some studies on why you would do that.
I have not seen any studies
and I've not seen any studies on why you would increase oxidative stress
to brain cells and healthy brain cells.
I don't believe it functions as an anti-inflammatory.
So, only for cancer is the answer to that question
that took me 10 minutes to answer.
Sorry.